hey what's going on whoa Jesus that's
love hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's time for the Monday morning
podcast get this down here hey hey hey
hey all right there we go there we go
see I don't need a producer is sorry
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast yeah and I'm just checking in on
you oh Jesus Christ
overrated underrated we're doing this
one early uh underrated not having [ __ ]
to do not having [ __ ] going on in your
[ __ ] life and the phone doesn't ring
you know cuz this is deal someday you're
gonna have [ __ ] going on in your life
and you're gonna look back to those days
when you didn't have [ __ ] going on and
you're gonna be like what the sitting
there stressing the whole time I I could
have sat around and watch reruns of Mary
Tyler Moore I could have watched The
Price is Right
you know that's crushing it right there
if you eat three meals in a day you
didn't go to work and you watch The
Price is Right and you have the [ __ ]
nerve to pray to a higher power that day
go a little bit of blood it's such a
cruel world isn't it which of course I'd
be stressing out too if I had nothing
going on and I was sitting around
watching the [ __ ] Price is Right
you know Deaton White Castle I hop in
the morning just hitting all the [ __ ]
classic fast-food restaurants you can't
enjoy cuz these [ __ ] banker [ __ ]
they just want you to keep running on
the wheel it's unbelievable doesn't make
any for the whole way this thing's well
you know that [ __ ] [ __ ] that that kid
sent me in that they're gonna be trading
futures on people's or whatever the
[ __ ] expression is with people's
carbon footprint you know I think that
finally made me figure out you know
without any sort of research or context
to any sort of Bilderberg into inner
circle I think I just sat here and
thought about
and I figured it out because I didn't
discuss it with another human being so
it makes sense and now I'm gonna say to
you I think that that's why they don't
[ __ ] discuss the population problem
because they just you look at us like
the more of us there are the more money
they can make you know I I think I'm
into the conspiracy theory now that you
like there's a certain level of
sociopath you have to be the further up
you go in the power rankings of the BCS
you know white guy you know can't just
blame white guys you don't I mean
although we're having a hell of a run
this sociopaths in all races I don't
know what the finer you see these
[ __ ] warlords at [ __ ] I mean that
they're there they're doing the same
goddamn [ __ ] I don't know what it is
cult leaders and all of that [ __ ]
crap they just don't give a [ __ ] they
view it like this is my life I'm gonna
live from here to about here we'll say
80 90 years old you know if I'm lucky
right and the world isn't gonna end
during that time so I don't give a [ __ ]
what happens after me even to my own
goddamn children I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
not gonna be here just have an inability
to think that [ __ ] far I don't know
the more here about there's a couple of
candidates out there that are running
for president that I'm gonna vote for
and everybody's gonna say I'm wasting my
vote but I am NOT I am NOT voting for
[ __ ] this douche Trump and I'm not
voting for that [ __ ] idiot Joe Biden
Joe Biden's like the embassy like a
[ __ ] sitcom and they had the mom and
dad character he's like the [ __ ] dad
character and they gradually just write
him out of the script because he's just
not bringing I don't I don't [ __ ] get
it anyway but what is cool if you if you
do it just so you don't just listen to
the pontification Ziff someone who
doesn't [ __ ] read or whatever Joe
Rogan had [ __ ] Snowden as a guest I
mean that's a moment in podcast
testing history I'd say marc maron
having a standing President Barack Obama
who's killing out there on the road
everybody talking about Kevin Hart
selling out of football stadium you seen
what [ __ ] it Obama's been doing whoa
guys making money out there sells his
wife they're like the jay-z and beyonce
of political people you know selling the
same arenas never wrote a hit song oh
I'm back sorry about that the [ __ ]
goddamn machine just busted I was on a
nice little run they're talking about
the Obamas and the jay-z cz's and what
happened what happened you know what
happened my whole day went to [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know I was talking earlier
about you know what's underrated
underrated is having nothing to do all
day it's just scary when the reason you
have nothing to do all day is because
nobody wants you you don't have a job
ain't got no girlfriend right you ain't
got anybody I'm telling you right now
talking to you homeless people listen to
you I know it seems bad right now all
right you're using a dead bird for a
pillow but just know something it's all
gonna turn around and someday you're
gonna look back and be like you know
what is homeless as sunburned and is
chapped as I was I would give anything
right now to take a nap on a sidewalk on
a Wednesday afternoon just to have that
moment to myself that's something you to
learn when you're homeless the sidewalk
is always warmer across the street Oh
what's wrong with you I'll tell you
what's wrong B since my recorder went
out okay which I would love to sit here
and tell you that I handled like a
mature adult but I did
I flipped the [ __ ] out as I did since
you know in your world the magical world
of editing what I've done since I just
said you know before I said I was back
to the point where I said I was back I
went I got I oh bird over got my car
picked up from service I came back took
my dog Cleo
she's in town I'm taking it for a walk
every single day I took her for a walk
around the block I went over to Federal
Express I picked up a [ __ ] package I
came home I [ __ ] made breakfast for
everybody I thought people wanted
smoothies turned out people wanted
pancakes I adjusted I've made my
breakfast half time adjustments came
right back down stair did all the
[ __ ] dishes did all the [ __ ]
dishes picked up my wife's little paper
wrapper on a tea bag that she left on a
counter you know this is what kills me I
remember back in the day when I was
growing up in the military used to try
and make you feel guilty go do more
before 9 a.m. then you do all day go
[ __ ] yourself no you don't guys having a
great time hanging out with all your
friends singing songs write everything
rhymes you know [ __ ] out of here I'd
rather go March around singing some
[ __ ] dirty limericks and [ __ ] do a
bunch of dad errands do you know what
that's a that is a [ __ ] pet peeve of
mine as I'm doing it to you guys
I [ __ ] hate when people tell me how
hard they're working you know I don't
like what people dunk a ball and start
thumping their chest let me know how
awesome they are III don't need I don't
need any of that extra information I can
look at you I can see what you're doing
I don't know Kevin Hart I'll never get
over that
never so anyways let's talk NFL football
real quickly Jesus Christ what the [ __ ]
was that debacle
you know Monday night Patriots versus
Jets that wasn't even a [ __ ]
professional game alright and if I hear
one more jackass on ESPN
talking about the Patriots defense how
it's one of the greatest defenses of all
time ok they're obviously not looking at
our special our special our [ __ ]
Patriots the Patriots also did a Netflix
stand-up special all 40 [ __ ] eight of
them although what's-his-face Edelman
teaches him to do his impression of
Chewbacca he crushed it but anyway if
anybody looked at our schedule they
don't realize that we got the Cleveland
Browns this week we are just feasting on
bottom feeders so far I'm not saying we
have a bad defense I'm not saying our
defense might not be the greatest of all
time I'm just saying we haven't [ __ ]
played anybody and I'm not gonna [ __ ]
be the first if we do to the Ravens what
we did to the Jets Monday night then I
will be I will co-sign on what they say
and not the greatest of all time okay
but I'm just saying I don't know what
the bike but I always take the bait it's
just ESPN's job to sell these games and
tell you that what you're watching is
the most unbelievable thing ever and you
know nine times out of ten they're
[ __ ] wrong but sometimes they're right
like I remember a year or so ago what
Patrick mahomes came out and he threw a
[ __ ] screen pass and there and you
know what I made fun of that guy and he
was right Patrick mahomes is [ __ ]
amazing I hate that he's injured because
we're gonna be playing him and who want
what where's the fun in that you know
you want everybody a hundred percent so
then when they your team wins then you
can truly stand up right strut around
and act like you made some sort of
contribution that afternoon you know we
get a bill you ran a bunch of errands
and you want credit but did you make a
tackle on Sunday huh did you sit in the
war room making halftime adjustments
Jesus Christ the Jets quarterback had
[ __ ] mono it came back look like I
had amnesia Jesus Christ I mean that was
that was just that was an ugly
performance I got to keep I gotta give
it can I give a shout-out right now two
Jets fans you know everybody talks about
long-suffering Knicks fans you know you
know whatever Jets fans and you know
what it is it's not only that they keep
showing up it's the level of hope that
they have at one in four because they
beat the Cowboys the week before did you
[ __ ] see them and in the parking lot
I know the cameras on say they were
hamming it up but they really thought
that they were going to beat the
Patriots we turning it around that team
this is the second coming of Joe Namath
every [ __ ] it that's I know these
franchises that live in the past of that
one time they had a [ __ ] success the
Flyers the Jets all of that you can't do
it Red Sox did it with all that stupid
curse of the babe [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
saddled around her goddamn neck thanks
to guys like Dan Shaughnessy that was
one of the dumbest curses as one of the
stupidest things ever do you think
there's anything to it no I don't I
think we're just an inept franchise to
the point we have to make up stories
about ghosts and goblins all the players
that played for the last 100 years were
available for our scouts to see and
draft and we did not sir but if you want
to start talking about some [ __ ] fat
guy from a hundred years ago or a
goddamn goat I mean all right
up there on your sports widow walk pace
it back and forth one of my favorite
things to do is to argue with uh you
know I haven't been paying attention to
the [ __ ] World Series arguing about
Yankee fans about how great Babe Ruth
was or wasn't and like I always this is
what I always say I would say the guy
could play in any era but in this era
there's no way he wins his siyoung and
hits 713 home runs or whatever the hell
he hit I'm not saying he wouldn't do one
or the other you could be a sighing Hall
of Fame pitcher or a Hall of Fame hitter
absolutely but he ain't putting those
numbers up and people go why bill you
know
did you see Ken Burns documentary on
baseball on the fastball did you did you
[ __ ] see that I don't need to watch
that okay I don't need all the
information to have a strong opinion
know what this is what this is the stats
I look I look at people hitting 400 all
right and if you look at people hitting
400 it happened on a regular basis right
up until Teddy ballgame did it in the
1940s and you know there was times more
than one person hits 400 in a season all
right
this [ __ ] guy hit 400 over 70 years
ago and nobody has done it sense so what
do people say are they gonna sit there
and admit that the people they were
watching were playing in sort of a new
thing all-white sort of professional
beer league no I mean it's not a beer
league but come on they don't do that so
instead what they do is they start
inventing the ghosts and goblins like
Ted Williams eyes man he could pick he
could see the scene he could see it as
it was [ __ ] you know they always do
that [ __ ] come on the [ __ ] out of here
you know this should be an asterisk next
to all those those if you were [ __ ]
crushing homeruns or winning titles of
Stanley Cups and [ __ ] in the Three
Stooges we're still making movies I mean
come on what are we doing just the
amount of competition now that
everybody's you know allowed to compete
you know the the level of nutrition like
what you have to do to get an edge out
there the amount of game film that you
have to [ __ ] you can't sit around eating
hot dogs [ __ ] hookers on trains and
then going up there and just pointing
yeah it's all right out there he did
that in a major league baseball game the
[ __ ] out of here
all right you got a study game film you
have to be like you got to be like Tom
Brady knowing what the [ __ ] you gonna
eat 9 years from now right yeah [ __ ]
running with the goddamn tire strap t as
you carrying a desk whatever the [ __ ] is
these people are doing you know you
gotta let air out of a ball you gotta
film people from across the side like
now obviously if those guys all played
today they would be doing the same thing
ok they would also be you know taking
steroids whatever the [ __ ] they would be
doing alright eating power bars and
watching game films on a flat screen TV
absolutely but come on you are you guys
with me on that or do you think I'm nuts
or is it the greatest athletes for some
time for some reason we're just made a
hundred years ago um all right how far
we go five minutes on the first one so
much just 16 minutes here um anyways got
more football tonight my LSU Tigers my
adopted southern football team is LSU my
Norton one is Michigan because of
relatives I've watched them my whole
life LSU Tigers have Auburn this week
they're gonna get after it down there
mother than the warring old southern
Alabama well maybe it's in Death Valley
I don't [ __ ] know I really don't have
the time I don't know if I've let you
guys know how busy I am so I've given up
on knowing names in stats and it kind of
aligns with my knowledge of the game
anyways you know cuz before I used to
actually know the names of the players
and I knew stats and then I attached it
to my ignorant on in for
thoughts but now it said I don't even
know the names I think it'll be a lot
more palpable palatable is that how you
say anyway I did a great [ __ ] benefit
the other day for Crohn's disease down
at Largo and it's just one of those
great shows that they have at Largo was
just a mix of people that I don't think
would ever work together
it was Jakob Dylan Josh Homme E and both
of them played music sets and then I
went up and did some dick jokes
afterwards and we had the [ __ ] best
time and dude musicians are unbelievable
they were like what they did I was
sitting there like waiting to go on you
know on the side of the stage
listening to Jakob Dylan and he had like
two other guys up there with him of
course I should know the names but I'm
an idiot
in how good they sounded I was hanging
there with bartnik I go can you believe
like what we're listening to is live
like this isn't recorded that's how good
it sounded and then Josh came out after
that and totally [ __ ] crushed it you
know just I don't like to I'm always
envious of the vibe that musicians can
have with a crowd
I don't maybe if I wrote some nicer
jokes
I [ __ ] hate one of my actors right
now I was loving where it was at and now
I'm just um it's it's fighting me right
now you know you know like when you're
trying to make a point with your wife
and she's not listening so you try to
hold her down but she won't stop
squirming that is what I'm talking about
I'm doing that artistically with my act
how stupid was it that all those people
got upset with that [ __ ] guy you know
everything he can't get fired I love him
just like being an [ __ ] now the guy
he's just being an [ __ ] it's got a
little champagne in him he's being an
[ __ ] then all of a sudden people want
the guy to lose his career
it's [ __ ] unbelievable [ __ ]
[ __ ] like all of these [ __ ]
people that say somebody should lose
their job
I just wish like the feds would show up
at their house grab their laptop grab
their cell phone and just pour through
all their emails and [ __ ] everything
and it's like all right you just hold
them away from the people be like all
right before we go into this stop your
crying
before we delve into this we're gonna
give you one last chance
are you willing to delete your tweet
about this person you've never met in
your life or are we gonna go into your
smartphone and your laptop
find out all of your secrets and you're
gonna go down with them you have five
seconds four three two all right you'd
watch them all back the [ __ ] down
everybody's got something everybody's
got at least one [ __ ] dead pet that
they [ __ ] took a day out on buried in
their backyard oh come on bill is that
something that we need this close to a
weekend did we really need that you know
every once in a while you [ __ ]
flipped out
you pulled a Denzel you know denzel's oh
he's slapping liquids out of other
actress hands though he seemed to have a
drink in their hand and he comes over he
[ __ ] slaps it out of him I always
wonder if he says before the scene uh
hey what's your name
Frank Frank him do me a favor could you
hold a cup of water I said alright and
then you got to [ __ ] hold a cup of
water and it comes over yeah yeah all
right all right well she just [ __ ]
slaps in it it's one of my favorite
things in cinema if I ever get to do a
scene with that guy I don't give a [ __ ]
what my characters doing I'm holding
like a pitcher of beer or something
[ __ ] wardrobe people are gonna be all
pissed give me oh man he's gonna get wet
every [ __ ] take man we have three of
those shirts all right anyways as I was
mentioning listen to Joe Rogan's podcast
not like I need to promote it everybody
in the world is listening to it but
andrew.snowdon is on it which is just
[ __ ] amazing I'm Jesus Christ it's
incredible
hey you ever really been into something
any to try to convince somebody that
it's [ __ ] cool in there do they just
not having it and then for some stupid
reason you just keep trying to convince
them till it literally almost ends your
friendship with somebody I did that the
other day talking to somebody about our
Mercedes Benz AMG e 63 station wagon
it's basically a race car but it's a
station wagon and this person could not
get past the fact that it was a [ __ ]
station wagon and I kept going it's the
first time I said I was like no no no
then that's what makes it cool you know
and then by the end I said it how I said
it the first time on the podcast hearing
by then you and everybody in the Dairy
Queen's looking over they're stunned
their ice creams starting to pour down
on the [ __ ] hand it's just you're
like sorry I just really like this
station wagon I'm telling you right
[ __ ] now if I didn't love my car so
much and if I wasn't such a frugal son
of a [ __ ] I would buy one of those
[ __ ] okay
I would put my drums in the back I would
wait until three minutes before the show
I didn't have and I would drive to a
courtyard area I would set them up and
force people to listen to how much I
suck I haven't been playing as much as I
have wanted to lately because of errands
and I realized I think I need to get an
assistant I think that's how rich people
do it right I'm selling enough tickets
I'm paying enough taxes I need to
address the fact where I am right now
economically and I realized that once
you get to a certain level of wealth you
either get an assistant
or you adopt to inner-city children
that's what do you do that's gonna be my
thing except I won't raise them it's
just so they can do my errands right now
the world don't move to the beat just
one drum you guys gonna have fun doing
all the [ __ ] I don't want to pick up my
dry-cleaning go to the grocery store
pick up the package at FedEx quit your
crying
get on your bike I don't give a [ __ ] I
mmm sorry yeah I get an argument about a
goddamn station wagon so I'm trying to
prove it to the person I go look that
[ __ ] thing up on YouTube and the
biggest nerds ever are reviewing it and
none of them are you know if you just
look up the car and you do a review none
of them none of them have any audio
about how the car sounds none of them
are driving around fast they're all
driving it like a [ __ ] station wagon
this is the nerdiest people ever like
this car intrigues me because I mean
it's a station wagon and yet it has a
twin-turbo 647 horsepower that's all
this and they're just sitting there
driving along then there's this one
southern guy so at least you get the
list of that twang he's like I mean I
don't know why they made something like
this but I love it and it's got a lot of
pickup and you'd really enjoy it and
maybe you could also experience on some
level what I'm experiencing except
you're never gonna hear the engine do
one of the person is driving it through
a neighborhood going around an S turn I
mean I could I could have I could have
been on a [ __ ] tricycle keeping up
hanging onto the bumper and not tipped
over so finally what I had to do is just
type in the engine and then finally I
heard the foot and then finally engine
and then they finally get to see what
it's like it's a [ __ ] sleeper and I
actually I was so frustrated with my
friend that I actually went to their
website
I built the [ __ ] car the color that I
want
and the rims and everything and then I
took a picture of it and I sent it to
Dean Del Rey and Dean Del Rey or
immediately wrote back that car is God
and that's why I love Dean Del Rey I
mean dude dude it's it's it's it's a
it's a it's a it's a [ __ ] station
wagon all right just just go get your
Shelby Mustang you're [ __ ] jerk-off
all right you can tell by how cranky I
am that I'm approaching 48 weeks and not
drinking and I would love to tell you
that I've just left that habit behind
but I can I can feel it man
you know like in those horror movies
where you're running away from [ __ ]
Jason and he's just walking but for some
reason you never put any distance
between you and that that's what my
drinking is like all right I have a
little fridge out in the garage
everybody I'm not gonna lie to you okay
I got on the fridge out of there when I
open that fridge I'm not bill anymore my
name's Hank and Hank likes to drink okay
bill doesn't drink bill comes back in
the house and he makes pancakes and he
goes to [ __ ] FedEx and picks up the
goddamn package makes smoothies for
everybody abouts how your hand can't go
down the garage I actually have a
six-pack of Miller High Life one Bud
Light and some 100% pure cranberry juice
in my refrigerator let me take through
all of that the Bud Light I don't know
where I got that from all right cops
ever show up in this fingerprints of a
hooker on there I'm [ __ ] dead cuz I
have no timeline I don't know where I
got it okay I'm just leveling with you
and then the [ __ ] the Miller High
Life I was making some sort of stew or
something like that and you had to put a
[ __ ] beer in there some sort of
recipe I can't remember what and I just
didn't happen so I was like all right
well I got these out here for and I have
the fellas over which I never do anymore
cause I'm [ __ ] busy to watch a game
they can drink them so I got those and
then I got the cranberry juice because I
flew
from Tel Aviv to Newark had a four hour
delay on the plane and then flew to
[ __ ] LA after that it took me a
little over a day I think and I think I
had half a glass of water and I got off
the plane and the first time I went to
take a piss I thought I had the clap
fortunately I'm not out of banging it
was so I knew it was something else so I
just had to crush the water and I just
[ __ ] drank that cranberry juice so
there you go that's way more information
than you needed to [ __ ] know alright
let's let's read a little bit of the
advertising here everybody I think
mercedes-benz ought to do me a solid
with that [ __ ] you know the way
they're struggling having one yet
another on their way to winning yet
another Formula One Championship and
builders championship but does that
really have to do with mercedes-benz or
is that about the team itself all right
here we go we got three Reed's here
everybody feels do you experience stress
or have anxiety or chronic pain or have
trouble sleeping at least once a week
let's be honest all of those things suck
right I have stress yes do I have
anxiety yeah I think I do I have more
anger than anxiety I'm not as much
afraid of things as I am angry about
them maybe that's that's just how your
anxiety manifests itself alright I'll
buy this [ __ ] chronic pain alright
you're not alone remote many of us do
personally in your own words please
discuss the issue slash issues you have
and know how it kept you from living
your best life everyday well I haven't
adopted two inner-city kids yet so I
don't have a personal assistant so I
still have to run all my errands and you
know I got to tell you driving around in
my car
you know listening to satellite radio
you know after a while you know if I do
too many errands my feet get tired my
right ankle from going from the gas
pedal to the brake pedal and that gives
me anxiety and for first world nation I
could I think it also qualifies as
chronic pain and then afterwards when I
actually see real people in pain
homeless people and all that then I feel
guilty and then I have trouble sleeping
at least once a week I was searching for
anything that would help with these
problems people then I discovered feels
I won't do that to every time what is
feels feels is premium CBD delivered
directly to your doorstep I love this
[ __ ] I swear to god it's like
wintergreen gum for your joints I swear
to God you put it on your joints you
feel like your gum had some [ __ ]
Wrigley's what does feels do feels
naturally helps reduce stress anxiety
pain and sleeplessness please talk about
how much do I have to let these people
know it please talk about the condition
you have and how taking feels has helped
well my shoulders I have I have a frozen
shoulder and I put it on there and all
of a sudden it feels like my shoulder
joint has fresh breath for the first
time in months it actually it feels
tremendous I got the roll-on kind it's
one of my favorite easy to take place a
few drops of feels me he under your
tongue and feel the difference within
minutes oh I got the roll-on I got I got
to get the drops man real human support
new to CBD feel me offers CBD hot a free
CBD hotline and text message support to
help guide your personal experience feel
better naturally feels works naturally
to help you feel better
there's no hi hangover or addiction
that's awesome membership join the
fields community to get feels delivered
to your door every month you save money
on every order and you can pause or
cancel anytime
has me feeling my best every day and it
can help you to become a member today by
going to feels calm / / and who get 50
percent off your first order with the
fruit with free shipping that feels Fe
ALS calm / / to become a member and get
50% off automatically taken off your
first order with shipping feels calm /
BER all right quick what actually makes
a better toothbrush industrial-strength
power
claims of miraculous trendy ingredients
multiple models if you ask your dentist
they'll tell you it's less about the
brush and more about how you use it ahh
this is sort of like a metaphor for dick
size it's not the size of the boat it's
the motion in the ocean is that what
somebody with an average dick says
that's why quit was created by dentists
and product designers to folks to focus
on what actually matters for your oral
health
ladies healthier habits quips sensitive
vibration sensitive vibration ladies
with a built-in timer guide gently
brushing for the dentist recommended 2
minutes with 30 second pulses ladies and
sure he and even clean what exactly is
this thing that I'm selling here quip
automatically delivers brush heads to
every to you every three months for
clean new bristles right on schedule
the sleek intuitive design is simple to
use ladies comes with a travel cap that
doubles as a minor mount a mirror mount
sorry minor mount good habits mattered I
really gotta get glasses didn't I've
been trying to kill this fly for three
days and I have a flyswatter so it'd
just be a no-brainer I keep going to the
right I was pouring my almond milk into
my [ __ ] juicer right and I missed by
like a like not a bunch but like three
gulps went down the side anyways good
habits matter good habits matter to live
a healthier life [ __ ] so help from
so help form fresh oral habits with quip
quip starts at just $25 and you'll get
your first refill free to get quick calm
slash / o afriad get quip dot-com / /
this is a simple way to support our show
and start brushing better but you have
to go to get quip q UI p.com / bird get
your first refill for free go right now
to get clipped calm / / q UI p calm / /
o lastly but not leastly everybody its
butcher box alright when it comes to
meat quality matters but there's no more
to it than texture and taste
not everyone has convenient access to
high-quality meat now every month
butcher box ships a curated selection of
high-quality meat to my home all meat is
free of antibiotics added hormones each
box has nine to eleven pounds of meat
enough for 24 individual meals unless
you that skinny asian dude who eats all
the hotdogs and wins every year he
probably eats one of these every day
training training for that event packed
fresh and ship frozen and vacuum sealed
so it stays that way you can customize
your own box or go with one of theirs
either way you can get exactly what you
want it's the best meat ship right to
your door which means one less trip to
the grocer's options like 100% grass-fed
finished beef free-range organic chicken
my favorite heritage breed pork
wild-caught alaskan salmon you don't
know what it's gonna do and sugar /
nitrate nitrate free bacon I love the I
love the Heritage bread bread pork oh my
mouth waters every time I read of Jesus
Christ with Thanksgiving right around
the corner now is the perfect time to
give butcher box a try sign up today and
get a free turkey free turkey Jesus
Christ all that yeah why don't they just
come over and cook it for you plus $20
off your first box just go to butcher
box comm or enter the promo code bird
checkout that's butcher box calm or
enter the promo code bird at checkout
for free turkey and $25 off your first
box alright that's the podcast everybody
thank you for listening have a great
weekend you [ __ ] enjoy the [ __ ]
music here and then you get an extra
bonus here a half-hour Greatest Hits
Thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast see ya hey what's
going on it's Bill Byrne it's the Monday
morning podcast for Monday October 24th
2011 I'm actually doing it on October
25th that's two Tuesdays in a row and I
saw you guys bitching about it on the
Twitter who what's your cool is it
called the Tuesday morning podcast LMFAO
OMG epic fail ow go [ __ ] it I know I
understand I'm a little I'm a little
late this week I'm a little bit country
I'm a little bit rock and roll remember
that bit on the Donny and Marie show
those two creepy Mormons just so [ __ ]
squeaky-clean it made you skin crawl
they came they like desert there's like
I believe everything is round you don't
I mean round like one of those [ __ ]
wailing divas booties you know like you
can be so good you actually come around
again you become evil you know like some
of these oh these freaks where they get
so against abortion that they go out and
they commit murder but let's stay away
from that alright I think I've said
enough things about the bearded baby
haven't I so you're probably wondering
gonna hate Bill this is two weeks in a
row two weeks in a row wants to do I was
actually flying back from Stockholm
Sweden yesterday and I went from
Stockholm had to fly to Zurich which is
in switzer Switzerland and board the
plane there and then it was a 12-hour
[ __ ] flight all the way back to LA
and you think they just go a straight
shot right across the ocean that's not
how they do it you know because the
earth is shaped like a 50 year old
Bowler you know you know when you get
fat as a guy with like we just put it
all on in our middle that's like the
equator your belt buckle so you know
that's the longest way around so what
they do is they did it even make sense I
don't have to do it I'm [ __ ]
punch-drunk it's like 6:30 4:00 in the
morning out here it's which is like I
don't know what 4:00 in the afternoon
the way my head is that right now the
way my head is that where my head is at
right now and but it's pitch-black out
out here in LA we got it bill you
jet-lagged
stop making [ __ ] excuses if you're
not funny why don't what are you going
to take a [ __ ] nap don't waste our
times our times don't waste our time
so anyways how they fly you back does
they actually go fly up towards the
circle it's quicker way around the globe
mate we went right over the [ __ ] was
it Iceland then over Greenland and then
we came down over the Yukon Territories
in the Manitoba Saskatchewan [ __ ]
Alberta and then back into the States
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about but I had a great time over there
I want to thank everybody who came out I
would like to say ketose to everybody
who came out in Finland I'd like to say
talk to everybody who came out to
Stockholm Sweden and I'd like to say
thank you to everyone who came out in
London and thanks to people in
Copenhagen and Oslo because I didn't
learn how to say thanks in Danish or
Oslo knee in Norwegian you know that's
always funny I was actually being over
there after a while you started to pick
up a little bit of the language but uh
in typical American fashion I mean I
wasn't over there long enough I just
started speaking my own language and I
would always I would say hello but in an
accent I would just go hello
for some reason I would start talking
like that and like if you say hello over
there they know that you're you're an
American or whatever that you're that
you're speaking English because they
either say hey really quick or hi hi
say hi hi and [ __ ] Stockholm Sweden
it's hilarious you're standing at some
grown man goes hi hi and then a police
car goes by um but it was an amazing
experience and I sincerely want to thank
everybody I have [ __ ] amazing shows
over there if I do say so myself old
Billy Boy [ __ ] killed it over there
thanks to Charlie Murphy he told me
before I went over there he said go hard
son they can take it
so I said [ __ ] I'm gonna do my [ __ ]
like I'm standing in the middle of today
and that's what I did and it worked out
perfectly and the most interesting thing
the most interesting thing about the
tour was when I would bring up Hitler I
[Laughter]
got to tell you if you want to learn
some history bring up Hitler in Europe
because immediately people it gets
[ __ ] weird in the room because
basically wherever you go in Europe for
the most part he either completely
bombed the [ __ ] out of their city or the
city or in was on the same team with
them and there's a little little bit of
guilt because I've been doing this thing
where I am I am on a mission to get
Joseph Stalin to get a little more
credit in the complete maniac psycho
category you know what I mean like any
time they make a list of the top [ __ ]
psychos ever Hitler is always at the top
you know what I mean it's like one of
those Rolling Stones best guitarists
ever they're always gonna stick Hendrix
Oh Robert Johnson at the top you know
which I guess is right boy I don't it's
like what the [ __ ] the guy killed
he killed 20 million [ __ ] people
Stalin did Hitler only killed six
million you know wouldn't you think if
he killed three times as many as the guy
that everybody's saying
the most insane [ __ ] ever that
your name would get thrown around a
little bit more I don't understand it
you know what I mean you know what I
mean what you know it's you know what
[ __ ] Germany
I guess killing people in Germany is
like completing a couple of passes for
the New York Jets in New York City all
right
Adolf Hitler is the maque Sanchez of
[ __ ] it's the Mark Sanchez of [ __ ]
mass murderers you know it went [ __ ] it
I don't like I guess killing 20 people
in in Russia is like throwing for 400
yards in Seattle like nobody gives a
[ __ ]
you just gotta maybe you know but you
have like throw for 200 yards in New
York you know to me and then they end
the game if I can make it right with all
those [ __ ] self blowing songs that
New York City has concrete jungle their
dreams are made right so anyways I
learned all this [ __ ] about about Hitler
so I went to [ __ ] oh and I made an
ass of myself because of course I don't
know anything I don't know anything
about [ __ ] Norway Sweden copan hey
look in Finland I don't know anything
about him all I know is Sweden in
Finland have a lot of NHL hockey players
that's all I [ __ ] knew and as far as
my World War 2 knowledge I knew that
Hitler and Mussolini were part of the
Axis powers and that Hitler [ __ ] bomb
the [ __ ] out of England and then I also
know that he went head-to-head with the
Russians and they were treated right
before winter and the Nazis chased them
in and then they got surrounded just
like in a Bronx Tale then they closed
the door rights it started to snow and
then they said once now you can't leave
yeah everybody's gonna sound like a Nazi
by the way cuz I don't know how to do
anything in a Russian accent
already anything you know wait didn't I
know one da II do
oh I used to play Syphon Filter this
video game and there was this part that
I couldn't get pie
I couldn't get by this mission and every
time I hit reset like you had to sneak
down the hall and there was this Russian
scientist who was calling back to his
female assistant she would say something
you know nostrovia or some [ __ ] and
he'd be like dah
II do um anyways yeah Maureen
so this is what I learned in in Finland
this is their deal they sided with
Germany okay
so they get [ __ ] and it's embarrassing
because it's embarrassing cuz they went
with the guy who killed six million
people to fight the guy who [ __ ]
killed 20 million people I don't know
it's [ __ ] they'll basically if you
look look at them on a map well they
basically had the unlucky position of
being between two of the biggest mass
murderers in the history of the world
simultaneously okay so you know they
didn't have an army big enough to [ __ ]
with either one of them one-on-one they
needed to make an alliance so now you're
getting into self-preservation this is
how it was told to me in Finland now I
know there's a lot of Jewish people
right now listening going oh [ __ ]
Abraham whatever whoever the [ __ ] you
pray to who is your Jesus wait a minute
I don't [ __ ] know anyways he so this
guy told me over there basically that
they had to make a choice and they say
chose Germany you know which he tried to
say like we weren't down with that Nazi
[ __ ] we were just trying to make sure
that the Russians wouldn't take us over
and basically Germans helped out the
Finnish people and they put up this
[ __ ] Lake Placid epic [ __ ] battle
against the Russians and they defeated
them which is an unbelievable
embarrassment to this day to the people
of Russia this is the way it was told to
me in Helsinki all right
and I am a typical [ __ ] [ __ ] because
I didn't read up on any of this one guy
told me this [ __ ] and now I'm gonna
present it as fact so um I don't know
anybody read about World War two what do
you think about that because when I look
at it on paper it's like I get it okay
you got to so you're in between two
psychos you got to make a choice who are
you gonna pick all right the Germans
make an unbelievable [ __ ] car you know
you're [ __ ] you know they did an
incredible tank they had they they would
like the [ __ ] Steve Jobs they were
like they had all the [ __ ] and they were
in Russia what do you got you got a
bunch of [ __ ] people drinking vodka
who do we want to go up against we want
to go up with these guys who have tanks
that drive like Porsches or we want to
fight these [ __ ] drunks who got
[ __ ] dishrags tied around there of
their army boots what are we gonna do
here so I think it was like a it was a
[ __ ] self-preservation thing for some
because I think somebody like you sided
with Germany in just a second you do
that you they automatically go oh you're
[ __ ] and you know you're anti-semitic
and blah blah blah I'm not saying they
weren't not saying that weren't I'm just
wondering is there another side to it
where it's just like listen we were
trying to avoid being nuked so there was
a [ __ ] decision we had to make I mean is
there a right decision in that why don't
i [ __ ] read up on it instead of being
so goddamn lazy and then having you
[ __ ] read up on it and then [ __ ]
tell me about it alright so that was
their deal all right and then if you go
over to Sweden Sweden remain neutral I
really own by the way I brought I
brought up Hitler which bombed in
Finland and I guess someone's back say
it's going
does this guy realize that we were in an
alliance with Hitler in World War two
and it's kind of embarrassing at this
point
and I'm standing up there typical
ignorant American the [ __ ] you know what
do you guys into Hitler it's something
I'm making fun of the guy all I remember
is doing this bit like like Hitler's
always fascinated me in that I don't see
the charisma I just see an angry sweaty
ugly man who has completely lost his
composure during the middle of a speech
why didn't anybody go like this guy's a
[ __ ] spaz this is the guy we're
handing the keys over to bring us to
glory you can [ __ ] kid me this little
runt
by the way people at tallest [ __ ] in
Scandinavian and in all those uh
Norwegian countries by the way the
amount of like five foot two inch
children that I saw you know who was so
young like they voice hadn't even
changed and like [ __ ] almost eyeball
to eyeball with me going I'm gonna get
some Legos in Stein over the [ __ ] you
safe
[ __ ] freaking me out like I'm just
about five-ten I'm like average height
so I've never had an issue with my
height over there I felt short you know
it's kind of like Nebraska where
everybody out there is like 300 pounds
and looks in six foot four and looks
like they play for often offensive line
or some [ __ ]
yeah like I think it seemed like over
there like six foot one was like the 5
foot 8 or 5 foot 9 over here but anyways
so that's how I embarrassed myself in in
Finland how I was going who the [ __ ]
would follow this guy and evidently
Finland did all right that was [ __ ]
move and when I was in Copenhagen I
can't remember I told you this story I
brought it up I called them Danish I
said that the people of Denmark were
Danish and then I lost confidence in it
because nobody said anything and I go
I'm sorry Danish people from Amsterdam I
didn't say the Netherlands I said
Amsterdam and then I go what do you guys
markings and I knew that was wrong but
then I found out after the show that
they actually are Danish oh oh and it
continues when I went in Sweden and I
never told I didn't tell anybody this I
walked out on stage and said hey it's
nice to be back here in Switzerland and
everybody laughed thinking I was joking
and I wasn't I always get them confused
they both begin with s they're both in
[ __ ] Europe they both have those
blond-haired blue-eyed what do you want
to open the bank account that will cost
you two golden dragons so evidently in
Sweden what they did in World War two
was them in Switzerland they remain
neutral and before World War two I guess
Sweden wasn't [ __ ]
they were just eating potatoes and [ __ ]
there was an Irish accent man Jesus I'm
all over the map here they were eating
potatoes and [ __ ] meatballs and you
know mashed potatoes and all that [ __ ]
they had nothing going on so their big
thing was they became powerful after
World War two evidently this is all told
to me by Swedes other comedians and we
were we were all drinking at the time by
the way I lost my sobriety in Europe as
I always do but I'm back on the wagon
I've decided that I drink in Europe how
[ __ ] obnoxious is that buddy you
didn't lose your sobriety you took it
and you flushed it down the [ __ ]
toilet yes I did yes I did
I was in but I was I was in Norway and
we're having a dis [ __ ] amazing like
meal and everything they were bringing
over was just tasted great and then they
had this wine and I said you know what I
wanted to go a year it was a year in two
days and I decided to end the streak
much like Cal Ripken jr. Ronnie was like
all right you know I went out like Cal
Ripken jr. I didn't go out like Brett
Favre you know laying there like I just
got hit by a train I didn't go out
that I had two glasses we want to hear
it you want me confess everything I had
two glasses of wine on Monday then I
didn't drink for two days and then I had
one beer in Finland tried one of their
beers delish then I went to Sweden the
next night and I had one of their beers
some summer summer ale now Pale Ale
that's what it was and then I Anne and I
had some single malt scotch it was
delicious and I enjoyed it and I'm done
and yeah that's it it's good it's
actually good because when I go to
Europe now I think about drinking but
when I come to the States
it's all been washed away like I miss
dates I don't drink here see that geyser
I I don't have a problem um so anyways
Sweden let's get back to these
[ __ ] and I know and I want all
you guys while you finish [ __ ] all
you Swedish sons of [ __ ] all you Oslo
Tian's and Copenhagen nights - please
send in more World War 2 information
because I don't want to read about it
you know what is going on with my
[ __ ] recorder come on now alright so
sweet and this is their deal they ain't
[ __ ] they actually used to own Norway
and then Norway got their independence
in 1905 right this is one of like the
most moronic [ __ ] history lessons
you're ever going to get so anyway so
Sweden wasn't [ __ ] and then in World War
two they basically remained neutral and
allowed the Nazis [ __ ] bored their
trains on their way to Norway to [ __ ]
take over Norway I guess and they would
just be like once we see nothing just
like sergeant Schultz on Hogan's Heroes
and evidently they sold weapons to both
sides huh see that it's all the same
[ __ ] doesn't that sound familiar if you
honestly look at a certain country's
foreign policy wait a minute you
out there and you armed the world and
made one yeah that's [ __ ] interesting
alright let's let's continue err
so where the [ __ ] am I in this this
absolute shitstorm of me trying to
remember what these [ __ ] these guys told
me ok so they totally sell out Norway so
the Nazis go in there they start kicking
the [ __ ] out of people because they have
[ __ ] they got these Porsche Targa
engines in their goddamn tanks you know
everybody else's tanks right this shit's
a sec
thank you we go like 60 miles a [ __ ]
hour to run so smoothly yeah right
and then just [ __ ] bombing the [ __ ]
out of in cbits Creek right bombing the
[ __ ] out of people then what did they do
the [ __ ] Nazis evidently go okay we
need to insert a new leader and they put
in this vid con Quisling who I guess was
total Nazi sympathizer and that type of
[ __ ] they put him in he shared their
fucked-up views of Jewish people and he
actually turned over Jewish people to
the [ __ ] Nazis that's what he did and
he's so infamous now and he's known as a
traitor in Norway and evidently his last
name is Quisling that basically if
you're if you're a piece of [ __ ] and you
sell out your friend it's called a
Quisling dude you want to talk about
just [ __ ] soiling your family [ __ ]
name you were such a [ __ ] that you make
your surname basically a god I'm gonna
be dumb again what's the [ __ ] word
you make now not a euphemism a an
expression for being a sellout traitor
piece of [ __ ]
and there you go and that's basically
that's world war two in Scandinavia in
one Norwegian country of Finland that's
basically what happened oh you know
what's funny about Finland Finland
kicked the Russians ass but because they
were on the side of the Germans at the
end of the war they still had to play
like [ __ ] reparations and they lost a
city and they had to give a [ __ ] turn
the city over to Russia even though they
kicked their ass now let's get let's get
into [ __ ] that I learned about as far as
their might does that mean my battery's
gonna die I think my battery's gonna die
here because it's starting to [ __ ]
crap out on me here this is one thing
I've learned as you travel [ __ ]
countries whatever country's border
other countries they don't like each
other the same way you don't like your
roommate you like him at first and after
a while the way he clears his throat or
[ __ ] you know his whiny voice or the
fact that his girl
friend is coming over too many times
after a while you just [ __ ] hate him
right so I guess the Swedes look down on
the Finnish people like to Finnish
people they're like the blue-collar
people they look at him like [ __ ]
whatever and then Finnish people just
think people from Sweden are gay because
evidently the way that they speak you
know I guess they have a sing-songy way
of speaking I it was too overwhelming
for me like all that all that [ __ ] all
sounded the same to me but I don't know
man it was [ __ ] amazing I learned all
this [ __ ] do you know that Norway a
Volvo comes out of Sweden right in
Norway at one point was I guess so
behind the [ __ ] 8-ball financially
that they actually said because they had
gained their independence from Sweden
and they actually said at one point that
they could hit that they would give
Sweden a portion of their [ __ ]
country if they could own 50% of the
Volvo car enterprise and Sweden said go
[ __ ] yourselves
and then like I think two weeks later
they discovered an unbelievable amount
of oil in [ __ ] Norway and now they're
all riches [ __ ] it was like it's like
the beginning if you don't understand
this just watch the opening song to the
Beverly Hillbillies it's the exact same
thing he was shooting its food and
bubbly and crude oil it is right so now
they became super [ __ ] rich and Oslo
was like ridiculously expensive it was
like $9,000 American to get a quarter
pounder with cheese and I'm barely
exaggerating it was like [ __ ]
ridiculous so evidently now in Norway
all those jobs like working at a
7-eleven you know helping people cross a
crosswalk
handing out flu shots all those jobs
nobody wants to [ __ ] and do all those
jobs are done by Swedes this guy in
Sweden goes yeah we've we've become like
they're Mexicans like we drive across
the border do jobs they don't want to do
and then drive back or live in little
shitty apartments out there
what is Finland export you ask Nokia
phones and Angry Birds that's them cope
and
I don't know what they do and that's it
that was my [ __ ] tour of if I don't
know I don't know what all Scandinavia
plus Finland I learned Finland is not
part of Scandinavia did I tell you this
last week I don't give a [ __ ] has any of
this been funny I know it's been
interesting especially if you if you
haven't read any bit of history because
this is all sounding factual and
fascinating I don't know how much of it
is right but if you don't like it blame
uh I can blame me I don't give a [ __ ] I
was gonna say blame the [ __ ] Swedes
who told it to me that night it's nice
to be back in Switzerland everybody was
like switz Swede the [ __ ] you want from
me we'd like you to be accurate though
we'd like you to if you're gonna fly for
14 [ __ ] hours to actually realize
where you are in the world
so anyways once again I know I was just
joking around and all that [ __ ] I
want to thank everybody came out it was
a [ __ ] unbelievable tour slash
education I think you guys made me a
little bit smarter yet a lot dumber
because I have all these new subjects
that I can talk about that I don't
really know anything about and Finland
to me was the most interesting because I
was basically 300 miles from the Russian
border and you know flew over the Baltic
Sea and it was like I could really there
was definitely just a different vibe out
there like they they got this whole vibe
out there that they don't have any rich
people in their country which is [ __ ]
hilarious because they have banks you
know and I guess in Finland the big
thing is you know if you get money you
don't you don't show it off that you
have it so it's like how the [ __ ] would
you this no there's no [ __ ] way
because one thing I learned doing this
tour is people are [ __ ] people and
like relationship [ __ ] that I was
talking about oh my god she tells the
story and it goes on and on forever and
I'm so [ __ ] bored [ __ ] destroyed
300 miles
the [ __ ] Russian border and I'm like
this is the exact same [ __ ] just speak
in a different language so completely
forgot my point here what the [ __ ] I was
trying to say oh I know yes so they're
trying to yep she's sitting there
telling me there's no rich people there
there's no way that would mean that you
have no screed ii people and no
sociopaths somehow you managed to have
millions of people in your country you
know yet you only have non greedy people
it's complete [ __ ] i got i got to
show you guys this picture of this on
the french riviera Rivi area rhythmic
riff e era that the the Rothschild
family built this [ __ ] house out
there okay and I want somebody in the
banking system to tell me how you
legally and I know it's legal but you
know there's no honest [ __ ] way you
see this [ __ ] house this villa
all right this thing is like the size of
like nine Boston Public Libraries it's
absolutely [ __ ] gigantic and this is
like a cottage they are the biggest
[ __ ] crooks on the planet they are
the biggest [ __ ] crooks on the planet
I truly believe there is plenty of money
tell me that I'm a socialist now because
I went over there [ __ ] you I felt this
before I went over there there is enough
money people there's enough money for
all of us to have health insurance
there's enough money for all of that
[ __ ] okay
if these [ __ ] at the top weren't taking
all of it I truly believe that but I am
not dumb enough to believe that if you
just give everybody the same amount man
everything's gonna be cool it isn't
there's got to be a way where you can
adjust capitalism well you can't have
like you know for robber barons taking
everything and then all of the rest of
us dealing with the trickle-down effect
but on the same level you can't just
give everybody like it doesn't make a
difference whether you try or not
you know you still gotta have it's like
the Camaro you know you got it you can't
just have does everybody gets a z28
there's got to be the rally sport
there's got to be the Berlinetta and
there's got to be the z28 there's got to
be a little does the little stars on
your forehead as to how well you're
doing you know does that make any
[ __ ] sense all I gotta tell my fellow
Americans is if you ever get a chance
you have to [ __ ] go over to Europe
and do it when you're young and if you
old who gives a [ __ ] get a babysitter
tell your kids you love them you know
you'll be back in a week go [ __ ]
yourselves don't take any [ __ ] just like
I weigh in my podcast and definitely go
over there
we landed in Switzerland and went on
Swiss Air on the way back and I just
watched a bunch of videos about
Switzerland and uh it would be an
absolute crime if you never [ __ ] go
there in your life the French Riviera
any of this [ __ ] and I know I'm sounding
like some elitist [ __ ]
but I'm not I'm not I am I am ignorant
of all of this [ __ ] I went over that's
it's [ __ ] incredible and I know
what's funny is when you travel over
there in that type of [ __ ] when they
start giving you [ __ ] about being an
ignorant American you know most of the
times you're more traveled than they are
they do the exact same [ __ ] they don't
travel as much as they try and act like
they do you know and when they do they
don't really go that far you just go
like just look at a [ __ ] map you
could fit like the majority of Europe in
Texas you know so they that's why they
get to rack up all these [ __ ] oh I've
been to [ __ ] Germany I've been to
France I've been to yeah really I've
been to Rhode Island no in New Hampshire
my voice cracked and all of them
whatever alright I'm done talking about
Europe I hope you got hope that didn't
bore too many of you but it was [ __ ]
amazing and I told all you sons of
[ __ ] over there that I was gonna I'm
gonna be doing this this every year so
every year you guys you're on the list
now I'm doing the I'm
do a whole run over there I think I
might add Iceland the next time and I'm
actually thinking of going over there
twice a year I'll do the the UK one time
go all the way through it I'll go
through England Wales Scotland Ireland
and then I'll do Scandinavia the [ __ ]
Norwegian countries do all of them and
just hop right across there and I found
a new [ __ ] place that I want to go to
the Faroe Islands FA r OE I want to go
check that [ __ ] out I gotta bring Nia to
because she gets freaked out by nature
Faroe Islands basically seem like the
Galapagos Islands of the [ __ ] north
alright I'm done being a [ __ ] liberal
elitist [ __ ] here alright let's let's uh
let's get on with the podcast here this
is the Monday morning podcast by the way
if you're just tuning in we are not on
iTunes okay because you know what
happened was basically I got banned from
iTunes and then Steve Jobs died so I'm
kind of like petros I'm in that
situation where Pete Rose got banned by
the commissioner and then he died right
after that and now nobody wants to
reverse that guy you know but how do you
go against Steve Jobs the guy was a
genius at telling people to invent stuff
as far as I can tell like wouldn't it be
cool if a computer could do this I want
to know where is the guy who actually
sat down and made his ideas come true
what about those guys
you know he's like the lead singer but
then the guy who [ __ ] actually did
all that [ __ ] he's like the guy playing
keyboards or the drummer or maybe the
hired gun I maybe like the hired gun
like that guy dizzy who was in Guns and
Roses towards the end remember that is
he left and then I got a guy dizzy yeah
was there any was there ever ever a
worst disintegration of a band than Guns
& Roses they came out they had their
five [ __ ] guys and then the whole
thing and just all went to [ __ ] it was
like mash when they had like three guys
left after the [ __ ] first season it
was
never the same BJ Honeycutt give me a
[ __ ] break alright let's let's
continue on here ah bill just an update
regarding your advice you gave me about
telling my friend about his cheating
fiance
I vaguely remember this this guy called
up and basically said a buddy of his was
engaged to this girl who was cheating on
him and what should i do should I tell
him and I finally just said yeah tell
him so you have a [ __ ] clear
conscience so here is the update the
other week I was high eating a Big Mac
and he should just said the other day I
was in Florida and doing sales calls for
my job when you read my advice letter
obviously I almost crashed but my
manager but managed to call my friends
that knew the story who also agreed to
write you an email about it long story
short we talked after we each listen to
the podcast I love that you guys had a
meeting of the minds after listening to
my dumb ass and the friend that
presented the bad news to us broke the
news to our friend oh so we [ __ ] told
him he could and I guess the buddy he
confronted his fiancee and as expected
things were only bad for a few days um
he doesn't really go into detail here
come on details what happened you can't
leave us hanging so you confront your
friend and what does he do he obviously
must have been like dude what the [ __ ]
you talking about and then he goes and
tells his fiancee said things were only
bad for a few days bottom line we all
got exactly what you said we needed a
clear conscience since there is
sincerest thanks Billiam alright well I
hope he had the brains not to marry her
um please tell me he did that just let
me know just yeah come on dude you can't
leave us all hanging here this is like a
soap opera now are you guys uninvited to
this wedding that shouldn't happen or
are you out there drinking with them now
trying to teach him how not to pick
another [ __ ] poison [ __ ] [ __ ] let us
know let's say let's have a follow-up I
mom I don't know about you guys but you
know this is like I just saw a great
pilot episode of a new show I
I want to see the rest of it all right
here we go uh next story is fake fatty
dear mr. burr on the whole fat person
topic I wanted to chime in with a quick
story of my own
last week I was on the subway [ __ ]
around with my phone when some woman
gets on the train and stands in front of
me from the corner of my eye I can see
that she was pregnant
I remember her rolling up her shirt like
we were on a beach and she was trying to
show off her physique that's kind of
weird and she began to squeeze the bump
like some strippers squeezing her
breasts together I started to gather my
[ __ ] when I noticed something about her
bump it wasn't a pregnant chick she was
a fat [ __ ] pretending to be pregnant she
was excited when she saw me getting up
and once I saw that hairy greasy
bouncing tub of [ __ ] a lump of [ __ ] on
her lower stomach I remember feeling
nauseated by it all I then sat back down
Jesus Christ the beautiful chick sitting
next to me saw the whole thing and
called me a jerk I didn't say anything
because I didn't want to start a
confrontation with her so I just sat
there so the beautiful girl began to
back gather her stuff I guess to make a
point and get up but then something
caught her eye and she sat back down I
guess she realized that the woman's
still squeezing her fat together wasn't
pregnant the woman sitting next to me
didn't apologize and neither did she
have to she probably would have vomited
the words anyways the woman pretending
to be training to be pregnant sucked her
teeth walked away and mumbled some
racist [ __ ] under her breath anyways why
are fat [ __ ] now pretending to be
pregnant I don't know about that dude I
think you saw one crazy girl and also
you know something reading that story
halfway through it she might have been a
fat [ __ ] who got pregnant maybe that's
why she was lifting up her bat belly to
be like look not only is there a bunch
of fat hair there's also a baby in here
baby maybe she was pregnant I have no
idea but that is really a [ __ ] weird
thing that she would pull it up and
start mushing it together especially if
she's early on in the pregnancy I mean
what's that
doing to the kid that's disgusting all
right and here's the latest you know and
I lost all momentum in this [ __ ]
podcast you know the old me would have
described some [ __ ] first trimester
fetus getting squished but not not jet
lag bill not jet bag lag [ __ ] bill
who can't even talk here who's sitting
here giving a goddamn history lesson of
a part of the world he knows nothing
about absolutely nothing all right all
right here's a new the new hot topic
here on the Monday morning podcast
dilemmas all right number one bill would
you rather have a three inch penis and
make 10 million dollars a year or of a
10 inch penis and only make $30,000 a
year your penis size and salary can
never change I take the 3 inch dick in
the 10 million all [ __ ] day long you
know you know what's [ __ ] overrated
just having a [ __ ] giant dick and
[ __ ] a bunch of women cuz eventually
you're gonna get old I know you guys are
thinking like this guy out of his
[ __ ] mind maybe it's just cuz I'm old
now and I don't give a [ __ ] it's just
you know what you want you want a nice
house you want to find a job that you
love and you want to [ __ ] make a bunch
of money out of it and then you want to
get the sickest grill ever and then
invite your friends over and have a
[ __ ] blob Yeah right what do you do
with your big dick and your teacher's
salary huh what are you gonna do [ __ ] it
cheerleader and get in trouble that's
all the big dicks gonna do you know what
maybe that's why you only make 30 grand
a year cuz he's too busy [ __ ]
everything I would definitely I would
I'd take the three in sure Jesus that
that would be brutal though that would
be brutal though when you first coming
of age you know I guess maybe not then
because uh hopefully you mess around
with a girl who hasn't seen a bunch so
she doesn't realize you know and she I
thought it was supposed to hurt the
first time I was actually rather planted
[Laughter]
yeah either one of those scenarios would
suck but uh you know dude
I want and all honesty how long does
[ __ ] last be honest let's say you're
really going at it come on
- really [ __ ] for a half hour or more
come on consistently consistently and
I'm not talking about when you [ __ ]
18 and every time the wind blows you
know you're [ __ ] aroused I'm just
saying you know you go in you do you
know what you're doing it's like you're
walking in Home Depot you're not
wandering around you know wish it is you
go and you get it you go up to the
register a [ __ ] end deal is done um
yeah I would take the three-inch penis
all [ __ ] day long if I'm a 10-inch
dick and sleep on a futon the [ __ ] kind
of life is that be an old man with my
long [ __ ] elephant trunk dick and my
white pubes on top of it poking out the
hole of my [ __ ] tighty whities
looking like the goddamn Elephant Man
down there I want to [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that this is gonna surprise
you guys ask me more you're gonna really
be surprised some of them would you
rather put on a Jets Jersey this is
number two and walk up to Tom Brady and
tell him to his face that he's the most
overrated QB quarterback in the NFL or
where the same Jets Jersey and walk up
to Mark Sanchez and tell him what the
straight face and insincere voice that
you think he's the greatest quarterback
that ever lived
I would do either one of those I would
wear a jet jersey and tell Mark Sanchez
he's the greatest quarterback that ever
lived cuz he wouldn't believe it
he knows goddamn well he isn't I
wouldn't give a [ __ ]
I had actually I would I would walk up
with the Jets Jersey and say that Tom
Brady's the most over a QB ever because
that's probably happened to him 9
million times I think every time he
walks into a stadium there's somebody
with the other team's Jersey on tell him
that he's overrated and then he's a [ __ ]
because of his haircut and yada yada he
doesn't give a [ __ ] I would actually do
that I would do that and I would say
something even meaner and and I would do
it right before the Jets played the
Patriots and then I would [ __ ] bet a
thousand bucks on the Patriots because
Brady would
come in and slice your [ __ ] throats
that was an easy one sir you got to go a
little harder all right number three hey
Bill I got a dilemma for you
yeah that's the topic by the way
dilemmas bill classic pain verse
disgusting one right here would you
1 take a 70% power Mike Tyson straight
left to the bridge of your nose nose
with MA MMA gloves on or lick the dump
that one of his diseased bag pigeons
leave on your windshield and it's fresh
ah no question I'd lick the [ __ ] bird
[ __ ] without a [ __ ] doubt I would lick
the whole [ __ ] thing I'd lick the
[ __ ] windshield clean rather than
taking 70 there's no [ __ ] way that
dude I'm old now I don't have pride I
have brains and I want to keep him in my
head that's the the young man says I
take this to 70% power punch both Mike
Tyson and then what are you gonna do
after that with your brain damage what
are you gonna do [ __ ] that I would do
the bird [ __ ] and I would invite all my
friends and I would film it like jackass
and watch them laugh their ass off and
if I puked I'd let Mike Tyson kick me in
the ass either way I would be way ahead
in the win column by not taking that
dude I got a little nose it would not
exist if he did it would it would be
like a little paper hat and he would
just flatten it and I would look I would
look a part african-american by the time
he was done with me that's how much he
would flatten out my [ __ ] little
pointy German nose no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way am I ever because the
thing about Mike is not only because he
know how to [ __ ] punch he has that he
goes in and out of crazy he'll say some
of the most insightful [ __ ] you ever
hurt in your life for you like this guy
I is a borderline [ __ ] genius and
then he will just slip into this [ __ ]
where you're just like okay you just
start looking for you know extra exits
in the room I like I'm saying this like
I hung out with them that's how
intimidating he is I've just watched
[ __ ] there so there you go you know you
know what I should start doing I should
start we should start having like a
football pool you know we should start
posting these these dilemmas on the mmm
podcast calm and then you guys try to
guess which one I'm gonna take alright
so there you go you got to see me play a
couple of games here you know what sort
of scheme I'm running let's see if you
can see if you guys can get my [ __ ]
head alright advice on enjoying football
I'm guessing this is soccer or maybe
this is American football I don't know I
haven't read these [ __ ] things bill I
have an advice question that could
affect the podcast okay could you
somehow explain the appeal of football
to someone who finds the stereotypical
football fan extremely offensive to
clarify I enjoy seeing feats of
athleticism and well-laid strategies
unfold as much as the next man and I'm
told that football has both of those
things I think all sports do however I
find that I cannot even begin to enjoy
watching football for the simple fact
that I find the stigma of being a
football fan to be offensive oh god you
know what dude you're who gets offended
now this guy is a pompous ass all right
here we go you know the mental image
shirtless hairy and somehow balding what
do you mean somehow balding a lot of
people have bought I'm balding you mean
yet balding hairy body yet balding
beer-bellied face painted screaming
morons I was hoping that perhaps you sir
with your apparent knowledge of the ins
and outs of the said game as well as the
hoity-toity New England Li over educated
person accent that you sometimes your
insecurity there I sound like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I could explain the appeal of
football in an objective way to the rest
of us assuming the answer is not a if
you don't like football go
yourself um well look sir you're doing
what everybody does okay you're defining
football fans by the worst of football
fans and it's not your fault it's like
that [ __ ] I said about the Raiders you
go to a Raider game not everybody is
dressed like they're gonna go see
whatever that foot is that Midnight
Madness movie that everybody likes to go
see at 2:00 in the morning that I've
never seen I have that I always use as a
reference I don't know like not
everybody at a Raiders game is dressed
like they're in a [ __ ] musical the
Rocky Horror Picture Show they're not
dressed like that okay most of them just
had like a Raider t-shirt on or maybe a
[ __ ] jacket and they're just going to
a football game and anytime they pan to
people in the crowd they got to put that
douche you know who's dressed like
Chewbacca you know all those guys going
this is our house
and usually we could've lifted it and
they tried it's like your [ __ ] loser
they're [ __ ] losers yeah I don't know
what that that's not what a football fan
is and also sir you don't have to go to
games at this point you can get yourself
a nice high-definition TV that's cheaper
than buying season tickets you can get
surround sound you can get a grill going
and you can sit there in the comfort of
your own [ __ ] home and enjoy the
goddamn game all right
but I don't know I hate the word
offensive and that's that's my fault
that's that's on me because just being a
comedian the amount of people the kinds
of people who use that [ __ ] word I
find out like a fan sev it's like now
you know you don't find it [ __ ]
offensive you just find [ __ ] that bugs
you offensive you're not the kind of
person who's easily offended you're
[ __ ] selfish so this is I don't know
face makes sense guys I just get off a
[ __ ] point look dude if you want to
watch football
I would you I would watch at home
watching at home pick a [ __ ] team and
I would watch college football I'd start
with that and then work your way up to
pro or just stay at the college level it
is a [ __ ] great game read up on the
game don't be some douche who paints his
[ __ ] face in his chest and then just
watches the ball and roots for a color
it's all how you do it you know
lot of people out there who hate
stand-up comedy you know cuz they define
it by the worst of stand-up comics so I
don't hope that helped you I know I gave
you a little bit of [ __ ] and I hope I
didn't offend you but uh yeah that's
what I would do I would watch it at home
like I don't go to sports bars anymore I
don't they are a sea of [ __ ] morons
and it's for the worst of sports fans
they therefore the sports fan that wants
to sit there and it's just waiting for
the first play that their team does that
actually you know goes well with a game
like eight nine yards they're just
waiting for that to happen so then they
could then turn to their right or left
and just go right they're morons the
only good thing about going to a sports
bar is seeing the girls who go there and
dress like strippers with a football
motif like they tie off jerseys and
we're like thigh-highs and they just I
don't know what they're doing I think
they're just enjoying people leering at
them why they would pick that low grade
level of a human being to leer at them I
have no idea maybe they have some sort
of middle middle aged gangbang fantasy
you know and they wanted everybody to be
dressed like Vikings but Vikings don't
exist anymore so they're gonna get
gangbanged by some Minnesota Viking fans
I don't [ __ ] know [ __ ] food yeah the
other the other TV screens are so
[ __ ] loud it bleeds into the game
you're trying to watch it's just I don't
I don't like it I don't like it and then
I find that most people in there
if they haven't they know a lot about
the game it's because they play fantasy
football so they're just stat
regurgitating morons and they can't
really talk about the game when it comes
to sports bars alright let's go let's
move on advice bill let me start by
saying like your podcast thank you yeah
you're definitely but I will try my best
to keep the show you short and sweet
here's a little background first off my
friend is a listener of your podcast and
always and as well
first off my friend is a listener of
your podcast as well so I'm I feel him
hearing this on your part podcast will
catch his attention as he realize how it
exactly relates to him ah very very well
played sir so rather than you walking up
to them and they're having the
confrontation you want me to do it for
you okay
you hear that podcast listeners
evidently one of your friends has
written in and as a [ __ ] issue with
you so let's all pay attention shall we
why don't you scoot you [ __ ] driver's
seat up a little closer to your
dashboard let's pay attention and ignore
the [ __ ] lights just you know drive
like 35 miles an hour that's that's a
great speed plenty of time to [ __ ]
swerve my friend my friend decided to
have a kid with a girl he thought he
wanted to be with let me just say
capital letters bad [ __ ] idea
this girl is off for [ __ ] rocker for
sure I understand that most females have
may be insecure tendencies I think most
human beings don't to be fair but this
[ __ ] gives it an entirely new
definition it is to the point it's to
the point that she literally dictates
who we can and can't be friends with on
various social media websites as well as
the rest as his real life yeah this is
and whose fault is that she can dictate
all she [ __ ] once he doesn't have to
listen to it but if he goes all right
okay that's that's on him the real point
of my story comes now well thank you for
wasting my time
are you just painting a picture sir I
recently engaged in a debate with his
girlfriend about strip clubs
oh Jesus was that a mistake now I
suppose different patrons and I suppose
different patrons of strip clubs have
different reasons for going but this
girl has this twisted [ __ ] idea of
what actually goes on there the strip
club topic came up because a few of my
friends and I were planning on a night a
night out which included a possible trip
to the strip club once my girlfriend
found out
this was a potential destination she
flipped the [ __ ] out for lack of a
better word this triggered a huge
facebook debate where she insisted that
guys go to strip clubs to get horny and
if her boyfriend wanted that
why doesn't he stay home and get some
action from her well why else would you
go to a strip club
you are horny you have an inability to
get a woman naked that night and you
give up you just say yeah you know what
[ __ ] it why don't I just pay one to do
it and she'll rub on my jeans here yeah
and I'll bust one of my BVDs if you go
to a real [ __ ] skanky one so far I'm
agreeing with her why else would you go
there unless you want to go there and
try and [ __ ] a stripper at which point
you don't get the lap dance you hang up
at the bar
and act like you don't give a [ __ ] and
then from there I don't really know what
happens first off a stripper is much
more appealing than than this one what
the psycho girl even at the low end of
the spectrum but that's not that's not
that's neither here nor there all he's
saying that a stripper is much
better-looking than this guy's
girlfriend oh wow so this guys getting
dictated to by some [ __ ] mediocre
looking checked so sad you know that's
like a chick if you're gonna get the
[ __ ] kicked out of you the guy better be
like an oil man and you're living in a
villa in the French [ __ ] Riviera
right I mean yeah if you have to get the
[ __ ] kicked out of your ladies there's a
dilemma for you that's an easy dilemma
would you rather get this [ __ ] kicked
out of you by a substitute teacher uh or
uh [ __ ] the CEO of Exxon all right
survey says let me continue with this
she also had an issue with the fact that
these were local girls and for some
reason that pissed her off even more
well obviously because they live in the
area she's then worried you're gonna
strike up a conversation and bang him so
far I'm on this I'm on the side of this
this so-called crazy
woman she has this idea that her
boyfriend is apparently a stripper
magnet and can [ __ ] anyone he wants okay
I see what you sayin no I have no idea
how how far off base is this chick when
she said the guys went to strip clubs to
get horny that really showed how [ __ ]
moronic she is Mike real question is
what can my friend do to get his
girlfriend to turn the crazy off I've
been trying to help him for years but I
just can't find the way all right let's
stop here
sir why else do you go to a titty bar
you don't go there to look at chicks and
[ __ ] get aroused well what do you go
there for to check out the fall fashion
of thongs do you go there to drink $25
Bud Lights why do you go there you go
there to see naked women get lap dances
and maybe strike up a conversation and
get the [ __ ] one with their kid in the
crib in the other room that's why you do
it
isn't it hoping that their boyfriend
didn't get early release from his
assault [ __ ] conviction isn't that
what happens I don't know maybe I don't
[ __ ] know but he said what can my
friend do to get his girlfriend to turn
the crazy off you can't you can't if
someone's nuts the nuts that's it he
just got it well you got to break up
with him you got to walk away or you
have to accept their craziness
he said I've been trying to help him for
years but I just can't find the way
because there is no way sir it's like
trying to get a drug addict to stop
doing drugs you can't do it they have to
want to do it so he has to decide that
he's had enough all right and what you
need to do if you want to do this is
just Express the fact that listen your
girlfriend's nuts and she treats you
like [ __ ] and it hurts me as a friend to
watch this happen okay you need to get
her in line and if you do this this
could actually end your friendship with
them because guys a lot of times choose
[ __ ] confirmed [ __ ] I should say
confirmed [ __ ] over the friendship with
their their their guy's friends but
you know at some point you just got to
say listen dude I don't want to hear any
more stories about this girl treating
you like [ __ ] okay if you're not gonna
stick up with you for yourself I
understand it for whatever reason you
don't wanna do that but I don't want to
listen to you telling me stories about
what a [ __ ] psycho she is because it
hurts me as a friend to listen to you
going through this [ __ ] and you're not
doing anything about it
to stick up for yourself and it's it's
[ __ ] frustrating for me to hear so if
you want to talk about sports you want
to talk about the [ __ ] European your
Union or whatever the [ __ ] you want to
talk about huh you want to talk about
the [ __ ] I learned in Finland I'll talk
I'll talk to you about that I don't give
a [ __ ] right what do you want to talk
about talk about anything about that
crazy [ __ ] cuz I don't want [ __ ] to
hear it anymore that's your only option
there but other than that there's
nothing you could do as I always say
it's that Goodfellas moment he's I means
he's content to be a jerk so let him be
a jerk let him get browbeaten because
he's choosing the the crazy [ __ ] in the
hand versus the possible nice two in the
bush does that make any sense
well Bush is in there I think there was
some sort of Seinfeld feldy and joke in
that all right overrated underrated
overrated trying to do a podcast after
flying 12 hours on Swiss air you know I
feel like a boxer that's quit in the
rink I'm really trying to bring the
funny guys I swear to God I don't know I
don't know what I don't know what you
want from me you know you know I feel
like right now I feel like um I'm
playing like pop one or football and you
guys are my dad and you just saw that I
quit and that I don't have what it takes
you know and for half a second you're
blaming the sperm that was in your nuts
before you suddenly realized that you
can just blame it on your wife all right
overrated under it for the week underage
sandwiches we all you know we all eat
him yet rarely if ever hear someone say
that a sandwich is their favorite food
they are more versatile than any other
type of food and we take them for
granted
if sandwiches were women they would
divorce us due to under appreciation and
take half of our [ __ ]
all right yeah you know some people
actually don't like so I'm a huge
sandwich fan it's just a greatest idea
ever take two slices of bread throw a
bunch of [ __ ] in the middle of it and
throw it your piehole who's ever eating
a sandwich should still been hungry
afterwards it's tremendous you know I
don't [ __ ] am I still talking am I
dreaming this podcast at this point I
don't know overrated sex it ruins lives
and marriages thank you sir thank you
that's what I was trying to say why I
would choose a 3-inch dick in ten
million dollars a year as opposed to a
10-inch dick and 30 grand a year the sex
is overrated it started Wars and caused
countless deaths it's on TV and used to
advertise the most non-sexual products
you sell your social standing and job
credentials are affected by who you like
to [ __ ] what your social standing
junctions are affected by who you like
to [ __ ] I guess it could be if you start
[ __ ] the wrong person yet after
jacking off and releasing sexual tension
all of it looks stupid exactly rub one
out then think about it that's what my
grandfather always said even if he
didn't he [ __ ] should have now if
that's it that that is exactly it I
actually got this giant [ __ ] bit my
act about gold-digging [ __ ] and it
basically comes down to that I was
basically talking about Schwarzenegger
and how he lost everything by [ __ ]
one of the ugliest women on the planet
like why the [ __ ] you know if you're
gonna go all-in if you're gonna put it
all on the line why do you do that with
that woman yeah and everyone's like oh
cuz he's dumb because he's stupid it's
like no because a guy's sex drive is
that [ __ ] overwhelmingly powerful and
I swear to god it's like I really think
that every day you should just [ __ ]
rub one out rub one out and then [ __ ]
when she had done clean yourself up and
then get a sheet of paper out and write
down some goals for the day
and your life in the world would be
better off it's really it's [ __ ]
horrible we are basically designed to
keep the species going that's how strong
our [ __ ] sex drive is women don't
[ __ ] understand it and I don't expect
them to understand it and because it's
so bizarre to them they just look at it
simplistically that we're morons and
that we're animals and that we're pigs
we definitely behave like all three of
those things but it's a you know our sex
drive is like your period it causes us
to do crazy [ __ ] except it's not one
week of um it's every [ __ ] day all
right there's no excuse for the amount
of [ __ ] guys out there who've
accomplished all this tremendous stuff
to lose it because of their dick it
makes no [ __ ] sense and I'm telling
you these [ __ ] ladies who go on TV
and just say he's an idiot he's a piggy
still with their there that they don't
get it they just don't get it but I
understand why they don't get it you'd
have to have a dick to [ __ ]
understand it that's one of the greatest
[ __ ] overrated ever just imagine how
successful and how [ __ ] driven you
could be if you had your dick in check
you know if you could walk away from
that girl you shouldn't be [ __ ] around
with just think about that how many
years would you get back in your life
how many nights
how much more happiness would be in your
life if you just listen to your dick 30%
less think about that I'm telling you
I don't know but you you're really
[ __ ] with nature because nature made
women so [ __ ] beautiful
and guys so [ __ ] horny that you can't
resist it there's a reason for that it
keeps us it keeps us [ __ ] going and I
think that's gonna be my final
uninformed thought I've already acted as
though I'm a historian and now I'm
putting on a white lab coat and I'm
discussing are basically the the makeup
of our DNA oh [ __ ] so that is the
podcast for this week how much time did
I do an hour and five an hour and fine
from the bottom of my [ __ ] American
heart I want to thank everybody in
Scandinavia everybody in Finland
everybody in England who came out to my
shows it was an unbelievable education
as much as I sounded like a [ __ ] I had
it was one of the best tours I've ever
done just as far as getting to see
things that I never would have got to
see if I never took the chance to tell
jokes so I'm unbelievably thankful for
it and the amount of [ __ ] people when
I was over there asked me why would you
come here
and it kind of became this running joke
between me and Nia cuz we're big fans of
that movie no country for old man old
men chases I'm so [ __ ] tired no
country for old men you know and when
everyone kept saying to the psycho there
you don't have to do this and he's like
everybody always says that right that
was the same thing someone said why
would you come here Stockholm Sweden cuz
it's [ __ ] beautiful
I don't know cuz why wouldn't you if you
could know it's my game plan I want to
go over there and start selling out
shows come over there once a year make
some [ __ ] francs and crona's and
whatever and then [ __ ] go fly to
another part of Europe I never been to
for like two three days I want to go
down to the French Riviera and I want to
stand outside that Rothschild house and
wait for one of them to come up I just
want see what one of them looks like and
just stand there like nine miles away at
the
bottom of their driveway the biggest
bullhorn ever that's what I realized
that's what that Villa is that we're
gonna have a picture of that is they are
the plantation owners they're trying to
become the plantation owners of the
universe that's what [ __ ] the bankers
are it's just [ __ ] unreal do you
realize if you get a 30-year mortgage
and you pay it off in five [ __ ] years
let's say you do that all right what
percentage of that into a 30-year loan
is that let's see if I can do this math
this will be your last laugh of the
[ __ ] week listen okay ten percent
would be a third all right so you cut
that in half all right so that's about
fifteen we'll say fifteen sixteen
percent of the loan okay no you pay it
off in basically fifteen percent of the
actual time that they gave you to pay it
off okay but for some reason if it takes
you five years into that loan you still
give them like [ __ ] I swear to God
like thirty percent of the interest that
they would have got if it took you 30
years in how the [ __ ] does that work how
the [ __ ] is that legal
so even if you pay it off in five
[ __ ] years you still if you talk
about how much you paid for the house
plus the maintenance plus all the
interest the amount of time you're gonna
have to hold on to the house just to
hopefully [ __ ] break even before your
kidneys fail and you got to sell the
house because your insurance company
tells you go [ __ ] yourself and then they
get another 30 year old in here to do it
all over again they're [ __ ] criminals
absolute [ __ ] criminals but it's all
legal
it's all [ __ ] legal man all right
that's it that's the podcast for this
week
talk key - can I say it I don't [ __ ]
know thank you
go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you sons-of-bitches next
week I
you